Do you remember the
1999 NBA playoffs?
What about the 2019 playoffs?
This chart shows every spot
a player made a shot for both of them.
In the 1999 playoffs, the Orlando Magic attempted
29% of their overall shots
behind the 3-point line.
The most out of any team
for that playoff season.
In the 2019 playoffs, the Houston Rockets
shot 51% behind the line.
3-point shots have taken over
the NBA in a way
that’s totally changing how
professional basketball works.
The NBA introduced the 3-point line in 1979
as a way to boost points and
reduce congestion under the net.
DAVID BERRI: The problem you have is that
there is no player in the NBA
at that point who, can shoot a 3-pointer
on a consistent basis.
None.
David Berri is a sports statistician,
who is all about the numbers.
BERRI: Either you can measure it
or you can't measure it.
BERRI: And if you're not measuring it,
then you're just making it up.
In the 1970s, basketball teams
were used to focusing on 2-point goals.
Layups, dunks, and some
mid-range shots.
Shooting from far out was
an unnecessary risk without reward.
BERRI: If you were Steph Curry in 1978 and
you started launching 25 foot shots
your coach would bench you.
BERRI: The shot from 5 feet away is 2 points.
The game we play is throw the ball down
to the guy who's 7 feet tall
and let him shoot a 3-footer.
3-point shots were hard —players weren’t
used to making them.
And after Chris Ford of the Celtics sank the
first official 3-pointer in the NBA...
not much changed.
According to the stats website Basketball-reference.com,
in the whole 79-80 season
all teams in the league attempted
almost  7,500 total shots
only 227 of those were 3-point attempts.
And they only scored 64 of them.
It wasn’t until the 86-87 season
that the league made over 100 successful
3-pointers across one season.
In the ’90s, the NBA tinkered with the arc
of the line, moving it closer to the net
in an attempt to make scoring more points easier.
Players like Michael Jordan and Steve Kerr
took advantage of it
but it didn't produce the intended effect.
The league moved it back
just a few years later.
By the 1999-2000, 20 years after the
line was introduced
the entire league attempted just over 1,000 3s
out of almost 7,000 shots.
Fast-forward to the 2018-2019
and that number is over 2,600.
That’s an increase of 150%.
That shift has to do with one big statistic:
BERRI: 33% from 3 is as good as 50% from 2.
In other words, if you can make
one-third of your shots from the 3-point line
it’s as good as making half your shots
closer to the net.
DATOR: As the NBA has skewed
more towards analytics
It became a factor of like,
we should just be shooting 3s.
Like 2s don't matter nearly as much anymore.
James Dator is a sports journalist at SB Nation,
who’s written features on the 3-point line.
DATOR: Volume shooting from 3 ends up netting
you a better result than going from 2
assuming that you have the shooters
to be able to support it.
Daryl Morey, a longtime basketball exec who’s
obsessed with statistics
if often credited with figuring this out.
In 2014, he instructed the D-League
Rio Grande Valley Vipers
to cut out long 2-point shots
and shoot more 3s.
At the time, NBA teams were averaging just
over 20 3-point attempts per game.
The Vipers started shooting almost 50.
And Morey’s strategy worked.
They ranked first in the league in offense
and it was clear that they were going
to transform the game.
DATOR: What happens if you get 5 of those
guys and put them on your roster at once?
DATOR: Suddenly, instead of having all these
Swiss Army knives on a court,
you've got a bunch of scalpels, but they're all doing
what you want them to do
which is like, let's hit more shots from 3.
Soon, the NBA latched on and
3-point shooting skyrocketed.
As did 3-point successes.
In that 2019 playoff season,
the Houston Rockets
became the first team
to shoot more 3s than 2s.
This tool that started out as a
tough shot to make more points
is now standard practice.
DATOR: Oh, there's a very real chance this
is completely breaking the game of basketball.
The fear is...
do we lose that kind of magic
and that element of
here are two teams approaching the game of basketball
with very different approaches
and let's see what happens when these styles clash
versus two teams that it just becomes a
who's able to shoot more 3s and
who's able to hit more 3s
and that's kind of it.
This becomes a problem when your team
can’t hit enough 3s.
Even Morey, who started the 3-point revolution,
has run into this issue.
DATOR: Now he's managing a team in the 76ers
where they don't have those 3-point shooters.
DATOR: So now it’s suddenly like, well,
you know, we can’t compete
because our best players
are interior players.
And even when you do have 3-point shooters,
there’s another problem.
DATOR: We could get to that point,
that it's just boring
because everyone's trying
to do the same thing.
There are a few options to fix these issues.
The NBA could move the 3-point line back,
to make it harder.
But that might not help forever.
The players are simply going to learn
how to shoot that longer distance.
And very soon you will find yourself
back in exactly the same position.
But now they're going to be
shooting 26-footers.
Damien “Logo” Lillard already does this.
In this clip from the
2021 All-Star game,
you can see him shoot
so far back from the line
he’s actually closer to the
half-court logo.
They could move the 3-point line closer
which would decentivize deep 3s
and encourage a tighter knit game
like there was in the past.
They could raise the rim, making all shots
harder to sink.
Or there could be more drastic changes.
DATOR: There are some wild suggestions like
limiting the amount of 3s
a team can attempt in a quarter
and then kind of like having a lightning round
at the end of the game where
suddenly you can just shoot
as many as you want for full points.
The NBA has no official plans
to change rules at the moment.
And even though there's a lot of commentary
about the 3-point line.
The statistics ultimately tell another story:
BERRI: I have lots of data on gate revenue.
BERRI: So I simply looked at what drives gate
revenue.
BERRI: Do teams that shoot more 3s
have more or less demand.
And the answer is it has no effect at all.
Fans don't care.
BERRI: The vast majority of your fans are
watching because they're emotionally attached
to the team.
That's what's important.